If you said 2/20, great work. We know 2 times 1
is 2 and 5 times 4 is 20. You might have also
put a different answer. You might have
reduced. You might have divided your
fraction by 2/2, and you would have gotten
1/10. Both 1/10 and 2/20 are correct.
Let's look at why. So here, I have two
candy bars. This top one's been put up on
20th. This bottom one has been split up
into 10th. I know that my answer was
supposed to be 2/20. Two out of 20 pieces.
Visually, I can see that's 1/10. I have
one out of the ten pieces down here. 2/20
and 1/10 are actually equal fractions.
They represent the same amount.
Oftentimes, you say that 1/10 is the
reduced form or the simplified form of
2/20. But as we can tell, both are
actually equal. They just look different.